officers attended her home address
shortly after 8 40 am on Tuesday the
25th of April and she was pronounced
dead at the scene
Maria was 29 weeks pregnant and I can
confirm that sadly had a newborn baby
did not survive
our thoughts are with Muriel's family
and friends and along with everyone
affected by this tragedy
we are providing her family The
Specialist support at this incredibly
difficult time
partner David Yates is wanted in
connection with Middle's day
at this time we have no information to
suggest anyone else has been involved
his vehicle which was appointed seat
I'll take her
was found at montclick Park on Tuesday
and an extensive search has been ongoing
at that area since
the last confirmed sighting of David was
on Sunday evening shortly after each
year
the subsequent movements that are known
after his vehicle was left at Mount
Country Park but there is nothing to
suggest he has left that India
we will keep an open mindedness as we
continue to search the area
a visible police presence will remainder
Country Park in Jewish Street as we
continue our investigations
that is not believed to be any risk to
The Wider public
however I would urge anyone with any
information or concerns to contact with
Scotland on 101 quoting instant number
zero nine zero four of the 25th of April
or speak to any of our officers
and finally and importantly I would like
once again to express our sincere
condolences to Middle's family and
anyone else affected by this tragic
incident
thank you
as you can appreciate the investigation
still ongoing so there's some
information I can't provide at this time
DCI was
can you realize if David Yates is alive
or dead what basis are you putting this
investigation on at the moment is he
dead or is he alive as far as you're
concerned
both of those factors still can very
much a factor in this I can't confirm
one way or the other four as however we
are both working lines of inquiry at
this time and do we know if he had any
links specifically to mugdock Country
Park at all as I've said it must be
my State's Foundation
he's away for that area
yesterday
from the information of course that we
have just now I can confirm that there
is no more
wider risk to the public could you let
us know when um
I can't provide that information first
we've got the ongoing terminal based
Edition
as you can appreciate this is a live
murder investigation as I provided in my
statement so I can't provide any of that
information to say you say David would
last clean on Sunday evening without
leaving the house with that at my dog
park it's part of an investigation the
information that we have is we've got
our last sighting of them at eight
o'clock and reward that last sighting
where was that last paper the last
sighting all of them was
um
Park is probably the base where I could
provide that just now and as I see with
no information that would indicate that
he has left that area at this time is it
any indication
as I said this is still very much forms
part of a live murder investigation so
that I'm very limited to the information
that I can provide to you
again that forms part of a ongoing
investigation is it
at this stage
so in regards to
the market investigation account provide
specific details at this time what I
would like to provide as we found his
card at Watford Park on Tuesday and that
is where we have forums own
investigation sense we have no
information to suggest
that is left that area and and again I
would just like to stress
have you spoken to morel's family and if
so you know it may seem like a stupid
question but how are they and how have
those conversations been I
just think it's a bit less time it's
very difficult and tragic times
we're using extensive resources just
known as you can actually see it look at
Park is quite a significant area in
itself so it was quite a large police
station so let's pay
information about
hey again that's part of the chemicals
do you think he has his mobile phone on
him or was it found in the car and so
obviously as part of an investigation we
have a number of lines of inquiry
Marketplace and that could form part of
that